here's a crazy crazy um
counter-intuitive thing about netflix
that most people don't know
which makes no sense but it's true
what's the likelihood of someone who
just has an idea so no screenplay no
trailer no artwork no attachments
getting a pitch
inside netflix
minus one to zero
unless unless they have an agent who is
really likes them a lot and wants to get
them in there first of all netflix
doesn't take unsolicited pitches none of
the streamers take none of the studios
or the streaming companies take
unsolicited pitches meaning you can't
phone them up
they don't have like a place a website
or an entry point where you can phone
them up and say i have a great idea i'd
like to pitch you it doesn't exist
i mean they publish that that's right on
their website okay
so the only way you can get in is with
either a agent
slash manager a lawyer so whoever
somebody who's connected internally in
there or a
distributor who's done business with
them all right that's the only way that
you can even attempt to get a pitch
so
so right away you can't get in directly
um so maybe you can get in that way but
highly highly highly unlikely also
because you haven't done anything before
i mean they have a lineup and i mean
let's talk netflix netflix has a lineup
at their store so long they have every
single major filmmaker in the world who
has done anything wants to do it for
netflix right because i mean they got a
gigantic audience right
so think of all the people ahead of you
in line and what their credentials are
relative to what your credentials are
so i would say if you want to attempt it
then
you try to get in line for an agent who
you're not going to get the time of day
from either
so then
keep working at your craft
sounds like don't don't don't just
expect to jump along here's the way to
yeah you're not going to jump the line
there's no way i can't even think of
getting lucky to jump the line
the the only way that you can sort of
get ahead a little bit is is do
something make something that is
notable that gets you that
that their usher says hey who did that
and takes you closer to the you know to
use a metaphor type of thing right and
that would be
here's a crazy crazy um
counterintuitive thing about netflix
that most people don't know
which makes no sense but it's true and
it's not just netflix by the way it's
pretty well all the streaming companies
okay it's pretty well all the big
releasing companies
the more
popular you have
the more success you've done in when
you've released your movie the more
attractive you are to netflix
so get this you want to make a move you
want it you want to get their attention
make a movie
put it onto youtube for free
create as much awareness as possible
spend you know
effort tons of effort creating awareness
get two million views
then all of a sudden you're going to get
onto their radar screen and everybody
says wait wait a second i just gave my
movie away to two million people like
why would anybody want it now after that
and i'd say
they would say because they have 160
million people and 2 million is a test
market for them and they just need to
see that hey people 2 million people
like your movie then all of a sudden now
they're going to be interested that's
the best way to get their attention
now how do you get that i mean you know
getting you you go viral you have a
great movie you create awareness that's
what this is all about but that's how
you get the attention of a major
streamer now it's as counterintuitive as
that sounds it's not really when you
think about the theatrical business
right
the movies that netflix wants the most
and all the major streaming companies
are the big movies
and you know pre-coveted the big movies
open theatrically to you know half a
billion dollars worth of business like
you know 500 000 or 50 million people
seeing these i don't know whatever the
numbers are didn't do the math properly
but 25 million people have already seen
the movie why would anybody want that
everybody's already seen it but yet
those are the ones that are most coveted
and have the get the biggest payoffs at
the streaming companies why because the
streaming companies believe that
people want to see them again these are
big movies and they'll want to be seen
twice
you know and then you know or three or
four times and that's why they're so
valuable even though they've already
been seen you don't use it's like love
you don't use it up there's endless
amounts so you know you don't yeah you
use up one view with a viewer but they
have ten more left or five more whatever
the case may be so that's why i'm saying
if you can release a movie an
independent movie and get tons and tons
of awareness
then you'll you'll get on the radar
screen a lot better you'll get to the
front of the line a lot quicker and
people will say okay i like this what
else do you got
so on one hand plan for success
submit to some of these higher tier
festivals
don't don't just assume don't rest on
that you'll get in but at the same time
don't sabotage yourself where you think
that you just have this amazing idea and
somehow you can get in to netflix to
pitch it
with no other vetting yeah i don't
believe in miracles but if you believe
in miracles like that would be in the
miracle category like i have a great
idea i've never done anything before and
i think that i'm gonna get in the door
on netflix and they're gonna fall in
love with it so to me that that's a
miracle that's like so far beyond
reality
um
maybe it's happened you know i doubt it
maybe it could happen once and maybe
everybody the myths and legends will be
created around it but
i put that in the category of a miracle
how about we move the needle a little
bit of miracles and talk about a
finished screenplay first finished
screenplay am i getting into netflix
you're still in the you're still in the
category of miracles you're just maybe a
little further down
okay yeah no you're if you're not a
proven writer first of all they're not
reading it second they're not accepting
it they're not reading it unless it goes
in through a literary agent who they do
business with which you can potentially
do that but how do you get that literary
agent you got to get them so that's
almost as hard as getting into netflix
itself so you're still it's it's tough i
know it's not like this is one of those
things where you know you say to speak
the truth and the truth kind of hurts a
little bit
um yeah it's reality so you've got this
screenplay you put your heart and soul
into it it's probably really good
and you can't get anybody to read it
so that's why sometimes you go down both
paths you spend a lot of time getting an
agent or trying to get an agent who
hopefully can get in the door and pitch
it to somebody but you don't put all
your eggs in that basket at the same
time you start to think about okay how
do i do this myself
maybe one happens before the other or
you know you never know
and we go back to the einstein quote
yeah so so you're not you're not banging
your head against a wall and you're
trying a different route which is more
of a proven route instead of my thing is
different because we all think our story
is special yeah and there's nothing
against anybody's story
or their writing or their skill but
you kind of have to go through certain
channels it can't just be yeah like
hollywood and when i say hollywood i'm
including you know like not just the
studios i'm including you know the big
streamers now and you know the basically
the people who control most of the
eyeballs
they've done a really good job of
locking out all the indies that's they
don't do it on purpose but the reason
they do it is because they deal in such
high caliber product i mean it's a
business decision right like they're
dealing in very very high-end production
quality
content and actors and that type of
thing and they just don't need to waste
any time on indie film production it's
just it's it's a nuisance it's
aggravating like
that's it any game they have so many so
much time in a day why would they spend
it on that when they have
the resources to do so much more bigger
caliber stuff which is what they're
doing like look at this what the
streamers offer now
i mean the value that they give to to
consumers 10 a month for like
multi-million dollar productions with
a-list actors and and fantastic
storylines and writing and everything
like that how do you beat that
like you're you know an indie film
producer like how do you even compete
with that so
looking at it from that perspective like
fear is fair right they got a business
to run they got viewers to satisfy so
and they have all the resources to do it
and and revenue coming in from
subscribers so why do they need to focus
on why does any exec at a streaming
company need to read an indie script
when they got 50 other scripts sitting
beside them written by in-house writers
who were you know high-caliber
successful you know people who are on
staff they don't
that's that's the reality because here's
the thing about indie filmmaking that
i'm going to give it credit for
it's generally a lot more creative than
than all than big budget film that the
big bunch of stuff is very well done and
i love it
um but it's
predictable it's formulaic it's you know
a lot of sequels a lot of stuff like
that because they you know they know
what the audience wants they just keep
giving them the same thing over and over
so you know the innovative stuff is
going to come from the indie film world
and the big studios know that it's just
very aggravating to access it all so
once in a while there's a breakthrough
and you know and they have lots of
innovation internally as well
they encourage innovation you know from
their internal writers
but um you know the cutting edge stuff
is coming from the indie film world so
that's where the indie film world has a
little bit of not an advantage but you
know you know it's a unique approach
but it's just a matter of organizing it
to get it through so that it can get
through the system
you